one of the victors of the day asharitha
you won this game uh first of all uh
before we get into the game itself
how does it feel to be back in st louis
pandemic certainly slowed a lot of us
down
and not getting a chance to play over
the board chess here your thoughts for
being back i'm really glad to be back to
playing over the board i think this is
my second tournament in like a year and
a half
uh i played one local tournament before
but besides that everything's been
online i was busy with school but
it's definitely different being back in
person and i really missed it
the excitement of playing in the u.s
women's championship again this is not
your first rodeo you're not no longer a
rookie
your feelings about playing against
these illustrious women
um it still feels like i'm playing like
for my first time um believe it or not
there's a lot of nerves uh but i
came to this tournament just
trying to give all my best every game
and i think i've proven in the past that
i can play these people so just looking
forward to winning every game
you won this game why did it happen here
uh i think i was
i think at some point i wasn't so sure
about my opening but after i got my
bishop pair i felt pretty good about it
objectively i knew i was probably not
winning in the middle game or anything
but i was always a little bit better it
felt to me
and i did think i messed it up
once i entered this bishop and queen
endgame but
my bishop and queen were super active
and your king was super weak take us to
the point where you feel like it was
dominant like which which move would you
say was was the key moment when you're
feeling like this is great as you have
we can see a position here
uh
but what what was the moment when it was
like this is this is where i'm gonna
start cooking
uh when she played g6 i was a little
skeptical about that move just because
it creates a lot of weaknesses on the
queen side i like if she kept her pawns
i wasn't really sure what i was going to
do maybe with g4 g5 but once she played
g6
i was happy to see that move i was
already thinking of ideas like rerouting
my bishop to f1 into c4 to target the f7
pawn
and so after g6 rook f3 i was also
surprised to see i think h5 a few moves
later
uh giving the permanent square on g5 for
my bishop
and
i think
i'm not sure if i reacted the right way
but i still played bishops i think i
played bishop c1 and i kind of expect i
thought i was i wasn't so sure about
rogue d4
um but rig d4 i was planning to play uh
queen f1 i believe
uh and to just give the pawn on e4
and then keep pressure on the f-file
that makes sense that looks pretty
strong it looks really strong
um but yeah after night e4 i knew this
was a mistake but i think i started
playing too quickly um rook f7
rook f7 and now queen f7 king h7 and i
think bishop d3 queen b4 which is
somehow i missed this move
but
i
played c3 uh
queen trying to get the better bishop
here with her weak king and then i think
queen g6 king g8 here i knew it was
winning but i wasn't exactly sure how
but i figured um just moving the pieces
around with the bishop better bishop and
queen
my king is relatively safe like
eventually it should have been winning
and i think
all of this felt fine to me and then
here
i think bishop g7
it that c6 pawn is really annoying but
so i was trying to reroute my bishop
and
i think h4 she took the pawn on b3
queen b2 king
h3 and all the yeah queen h5 i wasn't so
sure about but i thought um taking that
pawn
uh at the worst case uh like eventually
i thought i could reroute my pieces and
i like taking pawns
welcome to
very good very good this looks very
strong for you in any event it looks
like you mopped it up
really well
uh
you you say you're happy to be playing
and that's the final position there
you're happy to be playing
do you put any thoughts in your mind
like i want to win
uh no i just try to think what the
position demands of me to play um you
know at the back of my head i want to
win but sometimes you can't win every
game i'm not talking about the
individual game i'm talking about the
whole tournament oh uh yeah i would like
to win it's i this i think this is my
fifth championship
um and so
i definitely would like to make a mark
about this event
that's what we like to hear well
more games like this you're on your way
good luck and
we'll see you tomorrow thank you
congratulations ashita very